so AI or artificial intelligence is
perhaps the granddaddy of all
exponential technologies sure to
transform the human race and the world
in ways that we can barely wrap our
heads around so artificial intelligence
essentially means that we are creating
non-biological thinking non-biological
intelligence and increasingly
distributing our own creativity between
biological and non-biological props and
scaffolders artificial intelligence is
going to change our scope of
possibilities and ways they're only
beginning to glimpse try to explain the
nuances of Shakespeare to a chimp no
matter how smart the chimp is the world
of metaphor and language is simply
unimaginable to animals on the other
side of that line and so too what
becomes possible as we merge with
artificial intelligence is that forms of
creativity will be unleashed that we
cannot even imagine we're about to
transcend what it means to be human this
is going to be as significant as the
emergence of rich symbolic language is
going to be a singularity of mind a
Cambrian explosion of creativity and
insight and his Ray Kurzweil used to say
at the end of his book The Singularity
is near our capacity to create virtual
models in our heads combined with our
modest-looking thumbs and increasingly
combined with artificially intelligent
algorithms means that we created a
secondary force of evolution called
technology and it will not stop until
the entire universe is at our fingertips
human thought is about to be upended